[Music]
in copycat news in copycat news Chinese
factory Moos submitted by hello from
Sacramento was good with poppy now in
six a family in Toronto is suing their
neighbors for copying the look of their
house Wow Oh an original [ __ ] what is
that saying that should have been the
title unoriginal [ __ ] news you know a
lot of houses in well they're like these
cookie cutter KB Homes yella yeah the KB
home those KB Homes you know those yeah
KB home is a brand you know our little
since like the same team yeah the way
when we drive back to you where you guys
used to live the old house there's like
a KB home establishment being built
right there oh yeah yeah on that one
Street mmm looks at the freeway yeah a
family in Toronto is taking their
neighbors to court for copying the
design of their multi-million dollar
multi-million that's so weird because I
thought Canadians were nice
like when I imagine a Canadian like
seeing that someone copied their home
style they'll be like you have great
taste their body but maybe they're
annoyed because it there's something
that they like conceived themselves oh
yeah Oh buddy copyright your home you
can you can yeah oh [ __ ] so now you know
in this article they're saying uh so
this associate professor at this one law
school he ends up saying we often don't
think about architecture when we think
about copyright and we often don't think
about buildings as works of art so it
might seem like a particularly strange
person who homes I didn't put them in
the system you know why because we're
thinking like peasants true million
dollar home oh this is a multi-million
dollar home you're saying that they
spent the the original homeowners or
yeah the original home they
and about seven years to a tremendous
amount of skill effort time judgment
care and money has been across nearly
seven years in terms of designing
architect I'd be pretty much to make at
seven years if I design something for
seven years to make it uniquely mine and
all of a sudden my [ __ ] Cantonese
[ __ ] neighbor decides to copy it be so
bad exactly or else please don't let it
be Asian please don't let it be
it's the copycats Asian so the original
the contractors also Chinese so I don't
have photos the original people are the
ones suing their names are Jason and
Jody Technic
and the copycat errs is Barbara and and
Eric symbol yes they're not China China
yeah the China's people cuz that would
suck though like you're trying to create
this own thing and all of a sudden you
put the mind and thought into doing it
and all the sudden they did it in like
two like two weeks or some [ __ ] yeah
yeah I'd be pretty [ __ ] pissed yeah
so here's my point are they making a
profit out of it yes everything we
trying to throw at her she's like nope
it is cause we're just trying to play
devil's advocate and then put every
angle it's their [ __ ] ISM because I
would be bad if they were making a
profit out of my design
but if they were and they're just
copycat [ __ ] cuz they ain't got taste
I'll be like you cool so the technics
are asking 2.5 million dollars in
damages so it's 1.5 million in damages
20 thousand in statutory copyright
damages and 1 million in punitive
damages and did you just be straight up
about it and call it hurt feeling
damages I need 20 million because ma
Feliz is Harper yes so apparently the
copycats had their contractors go to the
originals home and they even told the
homeowners like hey there's this house
about 3,000 feet away that is trying to
copy you know your stuff so we're taking
a look at it because the owners saw that
they were these people were coming to
their home and just observing it like
what are you doing and so they told him
that and then that's when immediately
the original sent a cease and desist
order when they were building this home
but they ignored it
just like we're not doing anything we're
actually inspired by some other homes
this other type of architecture that
will tell them so they can sue you know
it's like a certain style of home from
like the UK and so they're saying that
yeah we're not a company you were
covering them or like so then that's
when the originals were like alright so
show me the the photographs of the homes
that you're saying that is inspired
you're inspired by and all they could
pull up there's just like generic
exactly I hate these people
and then they also said that they were
inspired by some castle and some James
Bond movie alive yes not Canadian at all
yeah then and then so they renovated
this entire home and they sold it for
almost two million more than what they
paid for the copycat copycat yeah so
they renovated this home and then they
sold it and they made a profit off of
these designs so I'm gonna show you guys
here so he copied the style yeah this is
original this is copy how dare they and
then even like the chimney style of the
door you [ __ ] frauds in the windows
and then even down to the color of all
window they even got the [ __ ] break
yeah I mean if they're using their
original design to create an artwork to
sell to somebody else as a purveyor they
do all the money yeah straight up yep
the architect should be butthurt from
all of this [ __ ] or the people that
collaborated to camp come up with that
[ __ ] yeah I would have been outraged the
original they're suing everyone involved
so it's like the homeowners which the
husband is a fillable tractor the
brother-in-law who I believe as a
contractor and the architect everybody
like they're just doing every one and so
they were in court for what seems like
about three years oh my god that's so
long yep and so after these three years
of litigation the two families they
finally decided to settle out of court
for an undisclosed amount and they're
saying that based on the circumstances
it just seemed like it was the best
for everybody involved dude the copycats
have to change their house that's the
thing that was one of the things that
the originals were wanting the
homeowners to do because I forgot to
mention the most important thing too is
the fact that because of them copying
the original it devalued the originals
home oh this is not the only house on
the block that looks like that now yeah
well it's on different streets like
3,000 feet away but yeah I don't know
host yeah probably I bet you they got
whatever money that they did but they
could they were allowed to keep the
house yeah I'm not sure they don't
mention the final thing if they have to
Tina I didn't mention that that was one
of the things that they were suing I
would honestly just burn that house down
well other people though they're
innocent people that have nothing to do
they said they bought the home no
Tiffany how come people have no shame
for copying like because it's a YouTube
world I would my soul would hurt like I
would be like oh I can't copy it's just
dumb idea dude we get that a lot oh yeah
all the time so our t-shirt designs
always get copied there's this one time
where there was this Chinese guy and I'm
not being racist [ __ ] exaggerate or
anything this guy from China came you
know
oh I love your gym or whatever like what
I'm like about normal yeah we thought he
was a fan and then my oh so you watch
your stuff he's like oh no I just helped
you guys and I like I like this gym and
then in front of my face you started
taking measurements of everything
because not have taken that measuring
tape let me get the [ __ ] out you know
it's crazy before you even said
measuring tape I imagine a Chinese guy
[ __ ] measuring everything and taking
pictures yeah yeah and then he would
spend an extra nameless yeah I was just
like mind-blowing I'm like you just
talked to me you know I'm one of the
owners and you're like now blatantly
like taking money Tom ah nothing cuz
then like I'm just like wait what is
this for I'm like are you a fan he's
like he's like I mean his English was so
[ __ ] up so I couldn't get out of there
but you know what everybody understands
though get the [ __ ] out that's a
universal language forever another thing
that's a universal language is a kick to
the stomach
and your girl so you could call rape and
be like well know what what what type of
kick to the stomach
what cuz I know there's different types
of kick so let me can I see huh this is
sparta sorry Julia
you're awesome Hey
so this is this is a copyright guy well
don't kick the [ __ ] out of Julia since I
fly off the handle is just wrong Chinese
a guy that's a taking pictures
oh shut up G yo shut up G oh yeah
[ __ ] garbage rice with soup that
almost hit careful nowadays so that's
the anti-rape kick right cuz the other
ones would be too aggressive I don't
want to do the side kicks or anything
else right yeah you just want to
rearrange his intestines you don't want
to break anything but a lot of people do
that even like in our area like our
small little you know black new supply
store that we have a Sacramento other
like competitive beauties pleasure in
there they would send people to come in
to check on our prices and see what
we're doing it's like but you know we
being Korean and very angry get the [ __ ]
out we know someone greens are scary
someone like that that just takes
pictures of your stuff and then and then
yeah they they just do the same thing
thank you know they have their own thing
that's like ours you know it's not a
moral I heard that it's not a moral
issue in China that's why he probably
did it in front of your face because
they don't have the same oh yeah they
don't have the same what do you call it
the IP yeah IP so for those who don't
know what IP is its intellectual
property your idea your [ __ ] you submit
it and then the government helps protect
that idea and because of that for them
it's okay if this exists in the world
it's okay if I measure it and figure out
how to do it myself so that's why it's
not a it's not a it's not a new lease is
make you a bad human being it's not
enforced very very strong should learn
American
customs in the best way to do i well
some say the best way to do is for they
kick their stomach leonidas foul because
then the other styles and get you in
trouble that's Martin that's my culture
yeah okay what's up guys how do we do
did you like it did you hate it well
guess what there's only a like button
and if you liked it that's the way to
communicate that to us so make sure to
hit that like button and for more
episodes click right above me
[Music]